[Music]
um
so i'm really excited to be here today
um to have this opportunity
uh to talk with you and be invited to
give a talk
and so first i want to say i get to be
the one here
to give a talk but what i'm going to
talk about today is the contributions
of many people that make all of this
work
possible and drive the energy and
enthusiasm
of this project and so much of what we
talk about i mean so just
in this room um contributing to the to
what i'm going to talk about today
we have mine and jenny and two of
our staff here carrie jordan and
francois bishono we have greg wilson the
founder of software carpentry jason
williams who served on the executive
council of software carpentry kate
horwick who's on the current executive
council karthik ram on the data
carpentry
executive council so this is really a
community effort
and so i want to attribute that and and
represent that in this talk
because it's a part of that inclusive
approach that we're trying to take
so i think we've seen throughout this
meeting something that's really
important
is that we now have data and tools to
advance progress and address
questions in science and society there's
so much potential in what everybody's
been talking about in the last couple of
days
with the data and then just i mean the
revolution in the
tools available in the art ecosystem has
been amazing over the last couple of
years
we're in a place where we were weren't
even a couple years ago
and we still talk a little bit though
about
the compute and the data how do we bring
compute to data
or data to compute but we need to talk
about
how we scale our impact talking about
bringing people to data
so you're in this room you could be at
any other talk
you could be doing anything else with
your life why
is this the most important thing to be
talking about
why is teaching people how to work with
data
we have a lot of social challenges why
is this one the most important
and so i want to point to this quote
from yeshumi milner
who's the founder of data for black
lives and that data becomes a tool a
profound
social change or a weapon of political
warfare
depending on whose hands it is in so we
need to think about
as we have this data that this data is
power
and that we need to democratize these
skills to give
people the power of thinking about where
they're headed
of how to interpret data how to use data
to answer the questions that are
important for them
so this to me is one of the most
important questions that we're facing
right now as we look ahead
to where we're going and seeing a
data-driven world ahead of us
in fact that we're in already so then if
this is the most important question
getting more people to be able to work
with data how do we scale the number of
people who can do this
um so that's what we're trying to think
about in the carpentry so the
carpentries is a nonprofit
organization and we're an open global
community teaching researchers the
skills to turn data into knowledge
and we do this through curriculum open
collaborative
curriculum an instructor training
teaching
people how to teach and community by
building and fostering a community
around these practices and about and
sharing knowledge
so i'm going to try an analog survey
approach here we'll see how it goes
um so in reflecting on your own learning
experiences
who in this room has been and i'm going
to tell you a way to answer this
question who in this room has been a
course or a workshop
where they felt like they didn't belong
so if you say yes to that we're going to
clap twice
okay okay so that's a couple people
good analog survey approach okay so how
many people after having that experience
left that topic for a while
[Applause]
so we have no idea how many people that
is but at least it's a few
right so feeling like you belong
in that course is really important for
how you continue
to learn that topic so
in the carpentries i'll talk about how
many workshops we've taught but it's
been a lot
and so something that we realized when
we were trying to measure our impact
or think about what was important is
that we realized it's not about a
specific skill set it's not about
can you parse this line of code can you
construct a function
in this way but that it's about
establishing a growth mindset around
data and code
and people feeling like they belong that
data science is for them
and so the growth mindset is a is a bit
of a loaded term right now
and does it work does it not work so i'm
not going to talk about that but what i
what i do want to say is what is it what
does it mean to us
right now when we say that so it means
confidence
the confidence that this is something
you can do or continue doing
that we focus on effort and incremental
learning and not
outcomes that you don't need to
immediately get something right
and seeing mistakes as opportunities for
learning and having an opportunity
for a safe space to make those mistakes
to continue learning
so we want to work towards this growth
mindset using inclusive pedagogy so
not focusing we do focus on what we
teach that is a big thing and i'm not
talking about that right now
but how how we teach and so that's what
i'm going to talk about now
and so we're thinking about it in the
context and for the people that are in
them they're saying i've never
actually heard it say it this way that
is true so we're thinking about
taking all of the things that we do
every day and stepping back and saying
what is it that this represents is these
four a's
accessible approachable aligned
and active so what do these things mean
in the context of a learning environment
accessible
so available in a time and a place where
people can attend
so that's really important right because
if you have things on weekends
and you can't you can't have child care
on weekends you can't go on weekends
but maybe you can't get away from work
uh during the week
or maybe you only can do evenings maybe
you only can do
online because you can't leave your
house there are a lot of
different ways that we can deliver
things so that it's accessible to people
in a time and a place that works for
them
that it's welcoming so that when they
are there
that it is accessible to them because of
the our environment that's created
so in all of our workshops we have a
code of conduct and we have a reporting
structure
those are both important not just having
a code of conduct
and we start with that i appreciate in
this meeting right that they started
with a code of conduct
because it sets the stage as saying that
this is a place that is supposed to be
accessible and welcoming to everybody
and being proactive about ensuring
accessibility needs
so i think we still have work to do in
this front
but looking at your website resources
looking at your color
schemes like a lot of great our packages
around that
looking at through the lens of
accessibility for
for everybody not just for the largest
percentage of learners
approachable so great this is accessible
i can go to this thing
but do i want to go is this for me
and so that starts at the very beginning
in advertising and recruitment for the
workshop if this is for beginners
say this is for people with little to
prior ex
no prior experience in this domain map
out essentially what your persona is of
this person who can come and tell these
people
who it's for and why they're welcome
invite them to participate
meeting learners where they are so
understanding that someone might be
working in excel
and that they maybe have you know
primarily only had experience with their
computers for netflix
that's not a bad thing that's where
people are let's appreciate where people
are and meet them there
rather than hoping that they're
someplace else and that is what helps
make it approachable we're creating that
on-ramp for them we're under putting
the on-ramp in front of them instead of
like way the heck over there
or a humongous step in front of them to
start and that helps overcome the
activation barriers to getting started
and then of course the mistakes are the
pedagogy so
in our workshop so we'll talk about how
we use a
like a participatory live coding
approach so you always make mistakes
when you're doing it
in person but we treat that as a part of
the learning opportunity
seeing other people when they make
mistakes when they don't know what's
going on
helps you understand one how you
approach fixing a mistake
and also that that's okay and i think
since we're supposed to quote hadley
that's something that hadley always says
uh is right that you know he has to
google things right
it's no not that everyone knows
everything and never makes mistakes
aligned so this is they're all sort of
similar
but the aligned is really about the
motivation
so teaching with data sets that are
relevant to the user
so we had a great discussion this
morning at the data for good buff
about using data sets that the students
were really excited about
and that got them excited about the
topic because if you're trying to
introduce some topic that they're not
excited about
and teaches skills on top of that you're
trying to do two things at the same time
so starting with a topic that people are
excited about
teaching the skills and perspectives to
the relevant to their
current work so yeah you might hope that
you know down the road
think that everybody should know c plus
plus but if that person is not going to
use it
right away in their context then it's
not going to be something that
that sticks that understands they
understand why it's important
and will motivate them to keep using the
tool
instructors that are current in the
field so peer instruction
so some of our best instructors are
people who were learners
only a year ago because when they
understand the misconceptions they're
very familiar with what that process
looks like so when they see that
something doesn't one doesn't understand
something
then they can relate to that help guide
someone through that process
they also are peers they're an ecologist
or a social scientist or an economist
and so they can put the things into
context and so it helps in guiding their
learning as well
and teaching the current tools so
looking around what is it that people
are using
teach what you're using in your work and
again that's going to be something that
helps them continue with their with
their learning
and finally active and this is one of
the ones that we really like to talk
about
and this is a little bit that idea of
guided practice that you can get
feedback on what you're doing as you're
learning
that's one of the challenges of learning
on your own is that you often can't get
that feedback right away
and so participatory live coding that's
the instructor at the front of the room
going through code and having the
learners go through it at the same time
so you're participating together and
doing that coding
and i we you model for teaching so i
describe something we do it together
you do it yourself it gives you a chance
to try it out on your own but not
completely without a safety net
all of our curriculum is open source and
collaboratively developed and updated
to represent the current practices so
our curriculum is active
actually in and of itself um oh i see i
care woo
in fact uh introduced tidy verse to our
data carpentry lessons
um so we have people who are in the
field that are active and engaged in the
topics so that they
kind of meet those first three a's we
have helpers in our workshop so not only
the instructor at the front of the room
but someone who goes around and talks
with people to create a strong like five
to one student ratio
and then finally our our most famous
probably is uh
is formative assessment through using
sticky notes
um so if so you completed an exercise
you put a green sticky note on your
laptop
and if you're having trouble you put a
pink sticky note and someone will come
help you
so it's a way during the workshop not
just waiting till the end and saying oh
my gosh did people get it here's the
survey
of seeing as will you go getting a sense
of the room
assigning help when it's needed so it's
a form of formative assessment
assessing as you're going during the
workshop
so that was a bunch like our whole
concepts of
instructor training that is two days
smushed into about five minutes
so you saw some of the instructor
training earlier this week if you were
there
but all of our instructor training
curriculum is also online
like all of our lessons it's all cc by
so the question is if what we're aiming
for
is confidence and continued learning
how are we doing how does this approach
work in terms of meeting those
identified goals
so first how many workshops have we
taught so since 2012
we have over 1600 instructors over 39
000 learners and we've taught over 1700
workshops
so not only have we taught a lot of them
we've had a global reach so this is a
map of the workshops
over time getting brighter in color as
we have more workshops
and francois did this great plot and i'm
super excited about it so
um and you can see we got antarctica in
the last year um
so very excited about that uh one person
taught that we think we should just put
her name on antarctica
she just claims the whole thing um so
we've also been able to have
because of this volunteer approach
approaching teaching from the
perspective
of meeting learners where they are and
scaling impacts
we've been able to reach a lot of
different communities
okay um so the first one we're trying to
achieve is confidence
so how do we do um so this is a survey
of students this is just data carpentry
um
it's not all our most data carpentries
are
but some are python as well so pre
and post two days how much have
people's perception of their abilities
and their confidence changed
um so the first question is i'm able to
write a program that would
solve small problems so we see these
full
point differences around write programs
i'm able to search for answers
i'm able to make my research my
programming more reproducible
overcome a problem become more efficient
in programming i know to keep my raw
data raw
i'm very invested in that question
and then that last one confidence in
programming so i have confidence in my
ability to program
that was one of our lowest scores right
before the workshop and it's increasing
a full point in two days
i mean you might say maybe that
confidence is misplaced after two days
um but the point is is that they feel
like it's
for them people feel like it's for them
right
and these are some of the words that
people use to describe the workshop
that reflect those ideals that we have
around inclusivity
inclusivity and accessibility and you
always see
instructors and helpful and so it
represents kind of a lot of those things
that i've talked about with our
practices
not only are people more confident after
two days
but when we survey people more than six
months after a workshop and this does
have a bias
because only certain people answer
surveys that you send out way long later
what is the percentage basically a
hundred percent almost 100 percent
of people more than six months after a
workshop say that they are more
confident i don't know you don't look
surprised i'm surprised
i just do programming i don't always
feel more confident after i spend a day
programming i can tell you
um so i mean this to me that is not only
the sort of short-term effect of two
days but the long term this feeling
persists is very important continued
learning do people go on to continue
learning
so this is again that longer term survey
have i have you gone on to continue
learning after the workshop so most
people agree or strongly agree that
they've gone on to continue learning
and these are using these skills in
their work
improving overall efficiency managing
data
so people are regularly using these
practices
again when they come back to reflect on
what this has meant to them what they're
capable of now these are some of the
words that they use
and they strongly recommend their
workshops to others
so you know almost 80 percent have
recommended the workshop to someone else
our net promoter score if your internet
promoter scores is like over nine is
that the right thing
it's the number of people that want to
recommend these to other people
also reflects on how they felt about
that experience
not just about what they thought they
learned
so safe space is for continued learning
that was that last one around a ghost
mindset because we want people to
continue learning how do they do that
so one way that they're seeing that
people continue to engage with our
community sometimes going on to become
instructors or helpers
but they do a lot of other things
sometimes they use carpentry lessons
they use short courses they go to
meetups they go to semester-long courses
so when we talk about this after the
workshop we do some of that but what
they're really doing is they're diving
into a community of practice and so
seeing these practices that exist is
really important and so we're lucky here
with our ladies and
all the things that people talked about
that they do have welcoming communities
of practice to continue to learn in
so these are some elements that make
this important
and so then the question is so great
awesome
people like it but i said at the
beginning that one of our goals is
reaching diverse communities
and how are we doing well gender i guess
would say
pretty rough this is just in the united
states because that's the only place we
collect demographic data because of
legal reasons we're not doing so well
so we need to do better so
there are elements of creating a space
where people feel welcome
there's more opportunities for that
there's more opportunities for
recruitment
and so what we want to say here is that
with this ecosystem with this community
of practice that people are building
with all of these different teaching
practices that we together are an
ecosystem
and that if we want to go far fast we
can go alone
and then if we want to go far we go
together and there's great opportunities
for that here
and we look forward to continuing to
work with
all of these communities and building
our future together around data
thank you